[Music]
to facilitate this discussion and
hopefully
[Music]
yeah thank us
thank you swathi okay I'm not a sigh I'm
more here to ask questions and to answer
them and I hope that we get a lot of
insight from the two other talks my talk
will has a little bit of very simple and
primitive math in it and so excuse me if
it's all too superficial but you know
you're the scientists I'm the I'm just
the journalist so I want to start out
yeah so the question is yeah is bias a
social or a mathematical concept can we
mathematically formulate what bias is
and what kind of bias do we accept and
what kind kind of bias don't we accept
so I I just construed a simple example
we have a community we're looking for
for drug dealers right and we have a
community that has only two kinds of
cars a Prius and a Corvette and from
experience we know that we have a lot of
Priuses and a very small fraction of it
and we have fewer fewer Corvettes and
just a small fraction of the Priuses
belongs to drug dealers like a hundred
of these 1,400 so they're one in a
fourteen chance of finding drugs in a
Prius and we know that drug dealers love
Corvettes and they so of these six
hundred Koretz we can expect like half
of them having drugs in them so now
we're putting up a police poster with
checking cars and we're stopping cars
and the in order to find the bad guys
and the question is what is the best
first of all what's the best method to
be effective and of course the first
approach is we check randomly right we
pick and that we can pick 200 cars
that's the that's my assumption so 10%
of the cars we can check
on that checkpoint in the road we can
check them randomly as they come by and
so we check 140 of the Priuses and we
check 30 60 of the Corvettes and then we
can the chance for each of the bad guys
to be caught is one in ten and how many
how many guys are we catching well 40
bad guys ten in the Priuses and thirty
in the Corvettes
that's a simple simple math example but
now one police officer has a great idea
and says hey we want to catch more of
them so why don't we just ignore the
Priuses and just just check the
Corvette's and that would be would be a
great success so I check only the red
cars 200 of them and zero Priuses and so
all the bad guys in the Priuses go come
away with that drugs they're not caught
the bad guys in the Corvettes are caught
with a Chance of 1 and 3 and so I catch
a hundred bad guys it's a lot more but
is this fair I'm a biased what am i
biased against well one argument is well
those bad guys on the on the Left they
don't have a chance to be caught at all
so I'm thinking of a third approach and
I'm looking at the 400 bad guys that I
have in this population and they're
distributed 1 2 3 so 1/4 is drive the
Prius and 3/4 driver Corvette and so I'm
saying that the cars I check I check
them in the proportion of this
occurrence of bad people so well if I
have 200 to check I can check 50 of the
Priuses and 150 of the Corvette and I go
ahead with that and now I catch some of
the Priuses 4 of them and 75 of the
Corvettes so if I'd to sum up my three
my three strategies
this is the risk of a previous guide to
be caught bad Prius to be called bad
Corvette to be caught and the overall
risk and these are the numbers so which
one is the best method what do you think
any opinions I don't really have an
opinion here I'm just asking the
question so from a mathematical or from
a legal standpoint what's what's the
best way to check for cars I mean in
practice I think police people have an
idea of you know how a car looks that
might belong to a drug dealer they have
prejudice
it might even be founded in in data but
can they can they turn this into
practice or do they have to apply that
totally random method I'm I mean on
purpose I don't include race or gender
or anything in this that it might sound
like like bias that's not a lot but yeah
how do you proceed here and this has
been a discussion in New York in those
stop-and-frisk discussions you know can
I can I just stop people and check them
based on how they look and there of
course race and stuff comes into play so
what's fair I don't know let me go back
to the to the source of this or one of
the sources of this discussion is the
discussion about disparate impact in the
US this was a decision in 1971 a company
was hiring I don't even remember what
what kind of a job it was but they
checked for if the people had a high
school diploma or it didn't IQ test with
them and of course they couldn't base
their their decision openly on race or
gender or these things but they base it
on those tests and then the court said
no you can't do that
either because it's an indirect way of
of judging people by their race or their
economic background because
people with a certain background have
don't have a high school diploma that
often or do worse on an IQ test and it
said the reason is the requirements were
unlawful and less shown to be
job-related
and so the question is what's
job-related here there are I did a quick
search it's very controversial if an IQ
is a predictor for how you perform in
your job I think it depends on the job
for some jobs it people say it's a good
predictor for others not but in the in
the age of big data so this court was
obviously talking about something that
could be shown to be related to the job
so so for example if you hire for for
construction workers who have to pick up
heavy loads it's not discriminating if
you don't hire a woman or or a you know
weak man that can't lift those boats
that's job-related but no well then you
can check if it's really true that there
it could have been an argument by the
employer to say oh we always have to
lift these heavy loads and in fact they
didn't right just to protect their their
practice but if we look at big data
algorithms they don't look for obvious
connections they look for the most
absurd connections and they don't
especially don't look for for causality
what it has to do with each other under
in the first order they just look at
correlations between data there was an
example of a company hiring programmers
and they found that all the good
programmers went to a certain Japanese
manga website and were you know like
these these Japanese comics and it
obviously has nothing to do with the job
but well what the hell right if you if
you find the people there and the good
programmers go to that website and you
look in
resumes and what their what their
hobbies and are then why not so but this
has had a lot of consequences and there
are certain classes that are protected
and their race color religion national
origin sex sometimes disability status
and age which you can't use in decisions
about loans or jobs or whatever and not
even you can even discriminate obviously
but it's also forbidden to discriminate
like indirectly through a parameter that
is somehow related to these and of
course the purpose of of these big data
algorithm is always to discriminate
right you want to pick the good
candidates and separate them from the
bad candidates and the software per se
doesn't know these categories it doesn't
know the indirect relationships and it
tends to give you a sample that it
discriminates as being the best
candidates for a certain job and then
you have to go back and find and see if
there's any discrimination against those
classes and since the question in the
beginning was is it a social
construction or a mathematical well in
the first place it's a social one
because these are the categories
categories categories we pick that
shouldn't be discriminated against and
that's not in the math so it's it's
about correlation and not causation if
we look at big data algorithms and
here's some two more examples a company
that does these job applications found
out that the distance from work so the
the the closer someone lives to their
workplace the more they're engaged in
their job and the longer they stay in
that job which you can think about why
this could be the case you think oh yeah
I have to commute so much I don't
I'm just stay in this job until I find
something better and so they offered
this to companies in their package deal
to pick their their candidates but then
company like Xerox came to the
conclusion no we don't want that because
if you just take the example of San
Francisco you have a job that this
downtown San Francisco then the people
who have a shorter commute tend to be
the ones who can afford to live in San
Francisco and the people with the longer
commute live in poorer neighborhoods I
don't know where the next the nearest
poor neighborhood is when you go from
the center of San Francisco but there
they have been stories recently about
you know people who commute two hours to
work to do a like housekeeping or
janitor job in San Francisco and then go
back to that to that neighborhood that
they can afford to live in so clearly
that would discriminate against certain
social groups I read an article so the
company evolved is the name of the
company that does these algorithms and
they've seen that it's a problem but
they're they're ambiguous about it I
don't know if who which of the customers
use that or not and another another same
thing is moving frequency so people who
move a lot they tend not to stay in
their job for so long which sounds
trivial trivial at the first glance
because yeah they're moving so they're
changing jobs but here the question is
what's what's the cause and what's the
result right so they might they might be
sloppy in their jobs and they leave and
they take another one and move or they
have to move because they lose their
jobs often because the job isn't well
paid and so maybe it's better to make
them happier at their job and then they
won't move that much so as I said these
these algorithms look for correlations
not for causation and it's known that
people in the with the lower social
status move more often
others and one reason is that they that
they tend to lose their jobs more often
there was this hope I don't bore you
with this example it's been reported on
that for an unattended consequence the
city of Boston had this program called
street bump where they made a cell phone
app that you have in your car and the
accelerate accelerometer recognizes you
know when you're going over a pothole
and it immediately sends the data to the
city and the city has a map and then it
registers where all the potholes are and
can improve the infrastructure come back
and fix the potholes but then people
found out that well especially at this
time I think now everybody has a cell
phone
even in poorer neighborhoods but for
example the tendency to to download an
app and use it in your car was higher in
affluent neighborhoods and so what
happened that the streets are what what
what could happen is that that that it's
a it's a reinforcing effect that the
potholes in the well of neighborhoods
get fixed more often and so the streets
are even better than in poor
neighborhoods and the the city of busts
and recognized these they were and they
they're working on it and I don't think
this is a permanent problem but is it
this is a sign of a very unintended
consequence of an algorithm that none of
the developers had even thought of right
they thought okay people have cell phone
and it's great that we can improve life
for everybody but it's not it's not fair
in the sense that certain social groups
are at a disadvantage so then the courts
in the u.s. looked at these lists and
said well when is when is a certain
selection fair and when is it unfair you
came to this 80% rule and I have an
example for that so let's assume we have
a job with 60
we have ten jobs in the company and
hundred people apply for these ten jobs
that kind of the same kind of job and we
have to pick ten people out of the
hundred and there were 60 men applying
and 40 women and we just start hiring
and we look at their resumes and pick
them out and we get seven men and three
women is that fair
or do we discriminate against them
obviously the the proportion of women is
even smaller than in the in the
applications and this 80% rule goes like
this we take the acceptance rate of the
man which is eleven point seven percent
here seven out of sixty and three out of
forty women is seven point five percent
and then we look at the relation of
these two numbers so and we find that
seven point five over eleven point seven
is sixty four percent so this acceptance
rate is only sixty four percent of that
and the rule is if it's under 80 percent
it's unfair and these women could go to
court and say you know I was treated
unfairly it's not they don't use it
consistently it's a it's a very big
legal system so but it's often been
applied this rule so what can we do here
for example we say oh yeah we we hire
five women and five men and then if you
take the numbers like that you find out
that you're discriminating against the
men because they are below the 80% so in
this numeric example the only thing you
can do is hire six men and four women
everything else would be discriminatory
it applies to all categories so you can
do black and white you can do and that's
that there has been have been court the
courts have decided about that
I think we're good that's that's a big
topic here right I mean that's what
we're going to discuss all day so now
what what the what's the question is
exactly yeah okay I don't know if
they're not allowed to have it or not to
use it right that's a difference right
yeah well that's okay so we're going to
come back to that probably later when we
asks how can we how can we test an
algorithm for its fairness right
basically you can you can even if you
don't know the algorithm you can treat
it as a black box and see what happens
if you put in a certain parameters and
what comes out and does it does it have
that effect right but there's it's a
it's very tricky everything is very
tricky here so I do some more math with
this example this came out last year
this is about a software that was
applied to predict whether people in
jail get probation so I released early
based on the likelihood that there would
be would reoffended commit a crime again
and ProPublica did a big study on that
it's it's this is a study done in
Florida with 10,000 inmates and they
came to the conclusion that this was
racially biased and they gave examples
in the in the story that you know a
black woman who had never had a lot of
if n
says shoplifted got in jail and got a
very bad score on this on this by this
algorithm and a white defendant who had
you know a long register of prior crimes
he got a very low risk so they looked
into the numbers and I do I'll show you
the numbers here because I went went a
little deeper and looked how they how
did they determine that so the first
thing we get is if you look at the black
inmates and the white inmates so they
get like a six almost sixty percent are
classified as high risk and with the
white guys it's only thirty five percent
is this racial bias we don't know yet
because we don't know what happens
afterwards right if they get released
who is it
is it justified to to assign this high
risk to them so you look at these
numbers oh yeah we can look horizontally
survived means that they so we look
after two years what happened to these
people survived means they didn't commit
another crime that's the terminology
they use to recidivate it this means
they they did commit another crime and
so with the black inmates it was like
half and half and here it was 60/40 so a
lot of the the number of whites who
committed another crime was a lot
smaller than the black so you might say
hmm is it is it biased maybe not maybe
they they had the black guys were the
more nasty guys the more evil guys that
thing that they had in this sample and
you can look at split this up by low
risk and high risk and what you see is
all these are these are big number cited
percentages too so you see that in the
in the black community 65 percent of the
low risk people who are classified low
risk really didn't commit a crime so
correctly 35 percent did but it was
pretty similar here and if you look at
the high risk people
like 1/3 of them did not commit a crime
although they were classified as high
risk and 2/3 actually did commit another
crime and it's kind of similar here so
there's no so where's the discrimination
whether the racial bias yeah yeah yeah
but that's the fine print there's
something more obvious here I go back to
the to the numbers and now I look at the
row I look at the columns but I look at
the rows and if I look at the survivors
so the the ones that that didn't didn't
commit a crime in those two years and I
look at the percentages now in those
rows I see that especially if you look
at the the false positive so the people
who didn't get parole kept longer in
jail but didn't commit a crime we have
45% here and we have only 23 percent
here so the false positives are a lot
higher in the black group and if you
look at the false negatives that's the
people who were considered low-risk and
released and did commit a crime then
this number is very high with the white
guys so if you look at the numbers like
this you see that the white people got a
lot better you know that their prognosis
was better than in effect the reality so
that's where those the
this the bias and the discrimination can
hide even if you know you look at the
data another way it looks pretty fair
and the last thing I did I went back to
my car example and the third method I
had for the for the Priuses and the
Corvette's and found of course if you
look at the false positives and the fun
and the false negatives here then you
get a result that a lot of the a lot
more of the of the Prius people the not
obvious drug offenders get away and you
have here you have a rate of 25% of
people who are being checked and and
searched and have nothing to hide so
yeah that was my little math excursion
but I come back to the to the question
and so I can make it I can pull up an
example with cars which is not a
protected item and for me most people
would say it's fair to look at a car and
then decide whether you want to check it
or not and be be biased against certain
certain types of cars because you have
to discriminate in your if you're a good
cop you have to you know find clues and
if it's if it's the color of our skin or
our sex or whatever we we all decided
that we don't want to discriminate
against that and so in this in this way
if you see it like that bias of course
is a social construction and that
doesn't mean we shouldn't we shouldn't
use these but it's something we decide
as a society that we don't want to be
biased against and so that's the end of
my talk thank you
[Applause]
any questions for now I think that bias
is a social concept
how many tickets am I to find a good
concept yeah and of course I want to
hear more about the math of it right
that's where we have the other let's
take a short break there's coffee in the
treats outside oh great